in this capsule we will introduce the
problem of machine learning
so this part of the court like
cautious goal to cover the concepts
basic in machine learning
so in English we say machine learning
machine learning this is the
machine learning translation
we will then see the deco algorithm
nearest neighbors to make the
classification in apprenticeship
automatic to those of his having
linear classification models
specifically the tax collector's grid
and logistic regression
that will get us to talk about derby
partial makes a reminder of the sounds derived
then see what are the derivatives
partial then also see what they
optimization by gaza centers
which is going to be useful in the context of the
linear classification and finally to
flight solve them in artificial who
will also allow us to make the
classification a different model
classifications and that will get us to
talk about rancial derivation and have
the the algorithm of retro propagation of
Christians so what is that
machine learning and more
specifically what we want
say by learning in context
artificial intelligence so we're going
to say that an agent to prince he is capable
to improve its performance on
strange future with experience it's
to say that as and when they
observe data in one of
observations in a given environment
we will say that I learn if he is
able to improve his behavior to
from the observation of these data
in the capsules we want to see
this capsule hoisted the next
capsule we will actually focus on
a relatively learning problem
5 kg super learning problems
use that one can formulate as if so
given a collection of data
who are going to be fathers entered and
associated outputs so she gave herself
we'll call it examples
learning
we will be interested in commenting on what we
can learn a function that can
correctly predict the output but for
a new entry that is not part
of our examples
wise so that's what they mean
by machine learning and
specifically we will talk
learning supervise how
can we take data
which are entries associating
outings and that we can have a
algorithm that's going to be able
to extract a function so a
program that will be able to do
predictions on news
inputs ideally who will be able
to predict the real output associated this
entrance so why is that in
do we want to schedule have
programs that are able to learn
so why not just
programs and programs that actually
do it themselves without having to
take it without having to find this
function there so sometimes actually it's
too difficult to anticipate all
possible entries that we will have to deal with
and knew easier in fact of
collect data that matches
to kotick that we think we face
in the future then to just say to the
program to adapt to these data there
so it's handy to have a
algorithm my agent who fits who
learns if the relationship between entry and
the output you want to predict evolved
of yesteryear so that's the case are at his fault
of the spam classification or
do the spam that can be done
know the 10 years are different this
that we are today just because
those who make systems
in your email and then that determines
how to write an email have adapted
their strategy in time for
try to outsmart the different
sensors the different classes ya of
spam and generally also
in fact often we have no idea
how in fact programmed this
function there desire in which predicts a
exit from an entry so in
what if it's basically basically
the only practical way really
achievable in practice the of getting
this function there for example one makes of
face recognition is very
difficult to come to define ourselves
a program that observes the different
pixels in an image that is capable
come to a decision on what is
the identity of the person in the picture
there are several types of problems
machine learning
the one we're going to focus on
in the next capture this is the one
capsule is that of learning
supervise so in this case also in
makes the exit that is desired or a
data entry will be provided
explicitly in our data and so
we will see fathers entered and
exits an example of problems that we
can solve with learning
supervise is that of the
character recognition and dense
that if we give drive our
learning examples will match
to fathers of image or some euros
identify what is the identity of the
character that is in this picture
there later other capsules we go
see also a learning tool
reinforcement learning and the
distinction is that rather than having
an explicit exit
actually our learning signal
information on comment what our
agents
our model will have to adapt your
correspondence that it is to
rewards or punishments
ok so and that's the type of learning
which will be useful if we wish between
others do the design of a model or
an agent trying to learn how to play
In chess
then in this case also actually the signal
learning the rewards the
punishments it could be that our
agent will receive a signal 1 for the body
or won a part is less
hour it failed and then the sooner
lost the part so in this case one
would have a punishment so in
learning parents inevitably we're going
design duty and seasoned who
can handle this type of signal
learning this type of data there
and there is also non-learning
supervised which will not be discussed in the
rescue capsules sis but when I
supports anyway when mentioned when
if at last we have data that
match only an entry and we have
no explicit signal on how the
model needs to adapt
so the model has to extract
information only from the
structure discovered inside the
entries so an example of that is so
we had several newspaper articles
we might want to identify what
are the different themes that are
treated by all those days there for
groups and group articles
according to these themes there is so this task
there it is designated in English as
clustering dip or in French of
grouping of articles in this case
we do not know for all items
we have in our data that they read
these themes question these themes and we
will develop algorithms that will
also try to identify
these themes automatically so that's
an example there are actually
several others that's the problem it's
learning and if you want in
know more I invite you to consult
the works that are dedicated to the machine
learning in machine learning